[Music]
have you guys seen
that viral video of this ukraine
news anchor who caught her own tooth
whoa
[ __ ] crazy what happened in the
middle of speaking and then all of a
sudden
i'll show you the video here we go
that's a nightmare
i hope it wasn't a real tooth and just
like a cab
[Music]
yes she looks like a jack-o-lantern
oh poor lady how embarrassing she kept
going she's so professional
exactly so i just did you see it fall
out because i didn't see it hits her too
it hits her lips let me run it back a
little bit
that's crazy he's a [ __ ] pro yeah
you look like a baby you can see the
whole afterwards that's what like
that's what like confirms that it was
her tooth oh that's so sad
there's children in these wayfarer
cabinets and if you buy them it's only
ten thousand
i always have dreams that that's
happening to me yeah me too
what a tooth fall my teeth are falling
yeah and i have to like and they all
start falling out
like high stress it means that you feel
like your life is out of control
basically does it happen to you guys
when you're facing a mirror
because it always happens to me when i'm
looking at myself in the mirror and then
i notice that i have missing teeth and
then more teeth come out
no in mine i can start feeling it and
i'm like yeah
that can't be it and then i'll eat it
sometimes and i'm like what the [ __ ] on
my closet
mine was brushing my teeth in front of
the mirror that was one two yeah and
then they're all falling down i'm like
oh no
it's breaking mine's never felt out in
her dreams you're never stressed
you never feel out of control it might
be i have wet dreams though
you know what's weird is my reactions
have changed though like i used to get
really scared i'm like i need to fix
this now and now
now my reactions and my dreams are like
well i guess that's what happened to me
now
yeah it was kind of like acceptance
just same that's literally okay like in
the most recent ones too
i try to put it back in i'm like oh dude
that's funny
i do i know what i'm dreaming so i'm
just like oh dreams you know you're
dreaming oh yeah dude mine feels so real
me too vivid so vivid sometimes i'll
have that'll happen
but most of the time i know i don't
think i dream anymore
everyone knows you guys don't remember
you just don't remember no because i'm
living the dream that's why that's sick
dude that was so sick what a good
rejoinder
i like it all right so the reason why
her tooth was
damaged to begin with is crack
she smoked crack she smoked cracks no
so one morning when she was sleeping
her daughter came into the room and she
was swinging around a heavy alarm clock
oh my god she just whacked her mom when
she was asleep
oh [ __ ] on her mouth and woke her up
like oh my god
oh my god they're saying that she opted
to have
radical repair but then she forgot that
the dentist told her
to not bite on any hard food until the
treatment ended
and so apparently that seems to be what
happened that she
ate something and then she ended up
doing her report
yeah what did you forget it happened
because
casey has recently been getting oral
surgery a lot yeah and
and like even though he's like in pain
like he'll still be trying to eat
something and then i'm like wait you
can't eat that remember he's like oh
yeah i forgot
he's a foodie yeah wait yeah did his
tooth fall out too
he wasn't born with a tooth oh he has
like a hole in his like
jaw like he just never developed bone
there and so because of that he never
got a tooth so his entire life he's had
like a bridge like a fake tooth but now
he's actually
fixing it permanently and that's the
reason why he's getting oral surgery
thank you for that i shall now call him
toothy hey tooty oh he has more than one
tooth
oh [ __ ]
that's not my teepee which is my
nickname oh come on you can't stump her
today you can't [ __ ] get her today
what does that mean
petey is just short for tiffany he
sounds like titties
it's actually aunt and tagalog too
because
no because our friend she's she tells
her son
to call me titi oh short for tv
so i'm like hey that's actually my
nickname nikki's tita and then i say
call me uncle tito because i just
i think it's a riot that's my brother
and my sister's name
oh that's uncle tito so that means uncle
uncle right well tito
and spanish is uncle
yeah yes when i got my wisdom teeth out
i couldn't eat for [ __ ] like everything
hurt i lost so much weight because i was
like
can't eat anything mm-hmm that should be
a weightless weight weight loss problem
i just want to get more teeth pulled
just so i can i'll hook you up girl
punch me get no don't do it
dude that's good reflexes though
nobody's talking about her refluxes no
everyone is
is saying like that's amazing how
professional she was that she was able
to
not skip a beat in what she was saying
that's the first thing that gio and i
said yeah
like and then and then the fact that
like she just caught it so quickly
yeah because i mean i think all the
farting anchors should like watch this
yeah cause we always see them and
they're like
oh yeah so eddie are the ones that
swallow a fly and [ __ ] they just go off
the rails yeah they're like
[ __ ] this country ass [ __ ]
place
and you're like what the [ __ ] happened
to professionalism and the guy who [ __ ]
himself
the weather man who shoot himself
remember him no oh
yeah yeah this is years ago but yeah he
[ __ ] himself pretty good
and yeah no professionalism there no
professionalism
he just shot himself in front of like an
on live tv yeah he basically should
himself that just kept talking about the
weather in florida i think
it was something like that i [ __ ] myself
on saturday why
why do you share this [ __ ] again what
happened not again
remember i told you yeah no i know you
told me i'm not saying that you didn't
i'm saying why do you share this [ __ ] no
cause i reminded me of
this [ __ ] it reminded him we went we
were uh so we went to go i was shooting
a shooting match with my buddy that's
why people like bart cause he shares
that's what this show's all about
sharing yeah over sharing
over sharing yep we're driving to uh the
shooting range
i just want to [ __ ] bart but then once
you get into the once you get into like
that area
you you kind of lose reception and stuff
and then so we didn't know where the
bathroom was so we found this like old
like
abandoned trailer park with a bunch of
trailers so he pulled over
and he's like my buddies i gotta take a
piss and i'm all calling to take a piss
too so we both stand in front of his car
and then we start peeing and then uh i
was like i picture you guys like
crossing streams or something i don't
know no just slightly
we're poli slightly around like around
the headlights go on the other side
whatever that doesn't matter no because
there's the public that way okay so
we we were very strategic about it all
right you got a plan so we stood there
we peed
and then while i was peeing i fart i had
a [ __ ]
of course i'm gonna i can't resist
temptation he knows so i push it
and then i push it i'm like no oh [ __ ]
push you don't
no i pushed it and then i'm like it
feels good when you push sometimes
though hey and
this my friend's name is don i'm like
hey don do you have uh baby wipes by any
chance
and then he was like yeah why you need a
sh uh you need to take a [ __ ] and i'm
like
yeah i already did you had a
oh so i had to take what did you do did
you abandon your underwear
no so i ran to behind one of the
trailers that's pretty big she probably
caught it it caught it all
oh so i pulled it down and i wiped
myself and i can't you need to eat more
fiber
if it just explodes like that like you
gotta have some solid
some more solid poop i like how you guys
found these abandoned trailers meanwhile
some family comes back later from a
fishing trip
and they come back to their trailers and
they're like what the [ __ ] who's [ __ ]
all over
[ __ ] all over the place they just went
fishing for the day
we just went fishing we're just
downstream
[ __ ] dicks oh [ __ ] like yeah it's a
an old winnebago i know so was it a lot
or just
like a little it was just little cause
like before i go shooting i like to
before you go shooting yeah because you
don't know when you're gonna see
like a legit bathroom so i always try to
take a dump in the morning
so i made sure i did that but then it
was just residual
you know residual [ __ ] so it was like a
little it was like
loogie-sized oh what the [ __ ] is brown
dude when you're when you're driving you
need a bathroom
and you see a mcdonald's with a mick
cafe oh
oh those are good yeah it's on
a lot of the times i like beautiful
targets or walmarts too
yeah because you don't have to do the
whole awkward like i'm not gonna buy
anything but i'm gonna take a [ __ ] in
your facility
you know what i mean you're just kind of
like ah yeah you have to ask for a code
though
oh yeah i'm like i just gotta go like i
don't wanna ask for mcdonald's in the
city
that's a cold thing dude they should ask
to the pea coat or a poop coat
that's amazing with that face
[Laughter]
you know a lot of you guys have done
live shows has anything ever happened to
you
in the moment where you're like oh [ __ ]
you had to save it kind of like what she
did with the tooth
i remember we did one in seattle and i
had um
and bart all of a sudden had to pee so
right when we were about to go up i
think he went and then
i went on we were we were hosting like a
show like with musicians and we were the
in-between
act and then um i i had to go up alone
and i was just stalling and then bart
finally came up like afterwards
this wasn't do you remember that it was
like a music show in seattle yeah
but that was like the only time because
we usually like
constantly pee while we're at shows what
happened during mafia at once to me
remember where like i had to
like i talked about this years ago but
it was like during mafia filming
and it was down to the wire you know
where i had to protect
the mafia or whatever the [ __ ] and
pretend i wasn't mafia
but also like my stomach was going like
and i was like
[Laughter]
not the [ __ ] mafia but part of me was
like just call me out so i could go to
the dead room and like
just [ __ ] figure it out guys
yeah so what happened oh i didn't i've
never shot myself
i don't have a [ __ ] myself like but
what how did you release
immediately after i just ran to the
bathroom so you had to win
because you're competitive winning yeah
when it took off and after you went yeah
and you're like
finally you go oh my god dude is
[ __ ] yourself as a chick hard
because
like [ __ ] into a thong it's like
what's the point i never shot myself
i have to [ __ ] in two you could ask me
what's up yeah so you're [ __ ] you're
basically [ __ ] through floss right
just
uh well if there's an accident i mean
yeah
but you don't feel it because it's like
it doesn't keep everything inside
yeah yeah it's just a nightmare scenario
you're wearing pants so that's what
keeps it in okay oh
wow ouch cause guys we gotta pretty much
wear your pants last time you were
wearing a fancy skirt i didn't [ __ ] on
myself
i shot on the floor in a parking lot in
pasadena right yep she's a responsible
[ __ ] i am what kind of that is
because i feel bad for wherever and we
can throw away our underwear
i did oh you could sell it oh girl can
sell it
guys can't there's a kink out there for
that no i'm all right all right
i i would feel really bad it's pandemic
so change your mind you should
hang on to those things i find guys are
more down to buy them when they're clean
underwear
yep if anything they really go down in
value when we [ __ ] them
you